yes let's transition into what boris
johnson just said yesterday if you want
to pull up that video we covered a lot
of different topics here
uh uh we we found out that abraham
lincoln is white which is breaking
extremely important if you want to if
you want to make that bigger uh this is
uh boris johnson he just said this
three days ago go ahead
mandate the wearing rewind a little bit
because you played it when i was
speaking a little bit the government
will no longer mandate the wearing of
face masks anywhere
[Applause]
mr speaker
wait
awesome
[Music]
are they booing him mr speaker from
tomorrow
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastery in classrooms
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
in the country at large we will continue
to suggest the use of face coverings in
enclosed or crowded spaces particularly
when you come into contact with people
you don't normally meet but
we will trust the judgment of the
british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one the government
will notice he just saved his honey what
do you think about that john
i think
british people just sound smarter
because of their accent but
yeah let
trust people if you compare the states
and i my last
video is about that how
there's just no pattern
states that don't require mass like
florida they get smeared oh more deaths
in florida than any other place and the
slimy media does this by mentioning
florida
when you have a bad month and ignoring
florida when the numbers are good
florida is number 19 in deaths and
florida has more old people so florida
is doing pretty well despite having
totally different rules and you
it's just not there it's the third
largest population in the country
new york uh new jersey did really badly
and they have tough rules so can you say
well locking people up makes
increased the problems from covid no
because there were fewer deaths in
california and they had horrible rules
so there's no pattern
and everybody acts like oh yes if you
only do this
you
will solve it but we're never going to
solve
covet it
it lives on in animals are we going to
require
lions and tigers to wear masks
we have to deal with this
it's a bad look lines look good they
need their their mouth
what would you say danielle
i think i think that we're learning that
that common sense as prime minister
johnson said that common sense should
prevail i mean if you're like in a
really crowded
subway car
in new york
and you don't have a mask on then you
you know in the event that you've got
me mine or lupus and i get covered and
it takes my ass down
hi i was in a crowded subway car with
people breathing all over me
if i'm walking down the street or if i'm
in a store by myself yeah and it's not
crowded and i don't have my
fine house is it going to come come up
and jump and
get me from some place across the street
no
where i live they're wearing masks and
outside i know i'm i'm in new york on
tuesday
that's the freakiest thing about new
york is that there's such a fear factor
i was in los angeles recently and there
are people walking on the streets empty
streets of los angeles downtown los
angeles and masks and i'm like
what do you think is going to get you
you're outdoors i mean that's why that's
what i'm saying government shouldn't
brainwash people out of having any
common sense
and that's what we've seen in america
and elsewhere austria just mandated
austria did vaccinations but fear is
such a powerful it is a motivator
and as a consumer reporter
i was eagerly covering every scare that
came by red dye number six uh asbestos
from hair dryers tylenol
tylenol why 2k it's going to crash all
the planes that's kind of like the new
thing there this g5 they're talking
about
one after the other
none of it happened you're going to get
brain cancer from your cell phone the
killer bees are coming up from mexico
and they're going to they're going to
sting but what they said about putting
metal in microwaves that was true
well that's true you laughed i made you
laugh oh my god that's the joke that's
the one that made you laugh the metal
and microwave jokes oh my god
tough crowd over here don't put metal in
the microwave so it's true but we fall
for it again and again it's it's fear
porn
fear porn i like that they're just
that's that's a huge hashtag yeah fear
porn i like that so it's no longer
what's that website cornhub is going to
be fear hub right all my twitter
followers pvd is getting to be really
active on twitter so all my twitter
followers you better be following him
wow so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]